Jordan peels get out had a lot to say
but us is arguably twice as ambitious
doubling down on both the horror and the
social commentary but if you didn't
quite catch what the movie was going for
and it might also be a frustrating watch
there's a lot going on beneath the
surface of this movie and we mean that
literally
the premise of Earth revolves around
sinister slasher movie doppelgangers is
show up out of nowhere with apparently
murderous motives it supposedly focuses
on one family the Wilsons
being attacked in a home invasion by
brutal copies of themselves but the
third out reveals that it's not just the
Wilsons having this strange experience
it's the entire United States of America
with an unfathomably huge amount of
doubles being led by a woman named red
the shadow version of Lupita Nyong'o is
Adelaide that's the first twist the
movie throws at you but the second big
twist to teased out slowly is that the
yadi the audience have been following
the whole movie isn't the original
Adelaide it's a double who switched
places with her at a young age during
the movies opening flashback scene
grownup Addie is haunted by an
experience from her youth when she
wandered into a boardwalk funhouse and
saw a sinister vision of herself but the
movie leaves out crucial information of
what happened to join that encounter
apparently reflecting the fact that
Addie herself as suppressed what
happened as she recalls she wandered
into the attraction found herself and
then shortly returned to a panicking
parents but as the final frames of the
movie reveal a whole lot of
consequential stuff happened during that
brief period like the fact that the
original Addie never came back in the
movies final moments Addie realizes or
perhaps just finally admits to herself
that she is a double from the
underground who strangled the original
Addie and took a place leaving the
original Addie shackled down below to
begin a new life as read one big clue
that this is what happened is that red
is the only one of the doubles I can
talk everyone else only emits inhuman
grunts and moans with red speaking in a
raspy damaged voice turns out this comes
from the damage her double did to her
throat when she strangled her when the
double entered the real world she still
didn't know how to speak leaving her
parents baffled at their thoughts a
sudden apparently trauma-induced
mutinous Addie spends the first act
sporting a serious sense of dread but
the twist changes our perception of what
that dread is all about Wallace played
somewhat ambiguous Lee it seems like the
adult Addie truly does not
at the beginning of the movie where she
really came from but she knows something
is wrong and that a reckoning is coming
I think it means she's getting closer
the first thing most people probably did
when they got home from seeing us was
google the phrase Jeremiah 11:11 which
turns up in the film multiple times
though translations differ the sentiment
of that Bible passage is pretty clear
it's payback time
the International Standard Version of
the passage translates into I'm about to
bring disaster on them from which they
won't be able to escape they'll cry out
to me but I won't listen to them it's
clear what's being set up here and us
versus them conflict between the
oppressed tethered underclass and the
ignorant privileged surface dwellers led
by read the original Adelaide one big
thing the red twisters is completely
recontextualized who the viewers should
be rooting for in the story red still
became a bad person but realizing why
she's so thirsty for revenge again study
makes her a sympathetic villain and vice
versa one person who clearly picks up on
Addie's otherworldly nature is her son
Jason who witnesses her growling and
snarling her way through several fights
in the movie well he doesn't say
anything about it he comes to
increasingly regard his mother with
apprehension even terror realising that
the woman he thought he knew may not be
the one she said she is at the end of
the movie as Adi realises a true nature
while Jason watches Jason pulls his mask
down on his head to which ad he smiles
in response putting on a mask of her own
at ease true nature as a tethered person
also comes into play during some of her
more inexplicable actions like getting
out of the car to watch the Soraa double
die or refusing to strike the double of
Jason when he confronts them near a
burning car her actions don't seem to
make sense until you understand what
she's realizing these people are her
people and maybe she doesn't want to
hurt them after all the question of who
created the tether doesn't get answered
and that's probably for the best it's
also what Jordan Peele intended with
many of the movie specifics being
intentionally open to interpretation
think of it less like a puzzle and more
like an ink blots I want to leave some
runway for people to explore what it
means to them while the viewer might
think that a tease visit to the mirror
maze is what triggered the creation of a
double the ending demonstrates that the
doubles already existed in the
long before she arrived how it's unknown
it's designed to be that way and it's
really not important no answer on this
earth would be as satisfying as some
mystery feels the most obvious
explanation is that the doubles come
from a secret government experiments an
unfathomable a massive cloning project
of some sort that copied every
American's body while failing to
replicate the soul but since the scale
of such an operation seems impossible
for humans to accomplish it's hard to
take this explanation at face value in a
logistical sense
nothing can explain how the doubles are
created much less how they got 300
billion pairs of scissors Freddy Krueger
gloves and red jumpsuits the fact is the
real villains of the movie are the
people who set up this terrains
experiments before abandoning its
subjects but whoever these people are
they never actually appear without the
ability to identify confront and fight
back against their real oppressors the
characters instead to tear each other
apart and that sounds like a big fat
metaphor for American society to us we
are our own worst enemy Jordan Peele has
described us as being about the fear of
the other and the self-destructive
tendencies that fear can cultivate with
this framework in mind the tether can
represent a lot of different groups
maybe us all the people that American
Society has condemned over the centuries
victims of the slave trade mass
incarceration racism or a predatory
class divide they represent the
Forgotten Americans who fall through the
white holes in the country's social
safety nets the people we abandon the
striking final shots of the movie show
these people stretched across the
continent in a human chain hand in hand
beneath the blue sky and the Sun for so
long they suffered living only a shadow
of a good life that their doubles
enjoyed not anymore though it took a lot
of killing to get topside but
considering the suffering they went
through it's almost hard to blame them
for making the effort
remember what red told Adelaide they're
humans too you know just like us check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more loop of videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and set the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]